[Music]
when we found this beautiful island I
really hope that one day I'd be able to
work hard and afford to come and live
here and then finally I thought okay
let's go and uh let's let's go and live
on Mecca and
and not to retire okay because I think
I've maybe worked even harder since
since then
you can hear the Lima's um
yeah calling in the background which is
uh they um yeah a lovely sounding early
in the morning
hello
you're looking very wet you're looking
very wet
most of the animals we got on this
island we've reintroduced so that you
know they used to be Scarlet Ibis uh
they used to be flamingos uh there used
to be giant tortoises and they were
killed off we've reintroduced them giant
iguanas the same and then there are some
species like the Lima that that you know
weren't in this area but um we're really
delighted to have they just eat
vegetables or leaves so there's no
downside effect of having them here
these two make love every morning
the the male one uh just says uh all all
the time what a guy what a guy what a
guy throughout the whole thing and then
when he finishes making love he just
goes
it's just every time
where do they get that from I I promise
you it wasn't me I don't know who it was
Rob